l'été je vais je viens de me faire
lourder
non mais que dire quand même prenez
l'avion moi j'ai eu la chance de ne pas
finir attachée à un arbre au bord du
périph c'est déjà ça et tous et tout ça
pour quoi un type juste parce que soi
disant c'était son mari
le truc est qu'à 45 ans une femme ça
doit penser à son avenir un avenir à 45
ans
l'immaturité des cadrages nerfs
moi je lui ai dit que s'il est ce cas
ces jeunes ouvrait les vannes puis
finalement non quand j'ai trop peur de
choper le tétanos
paraît que c'est un comportement
impulsif immature gamme embrasse le but
de la vie c'est de ressembler à edouard
balladur
enfin bref j'en profite et là pour
lancer un sos amoureux
sos d'un que tard en détresse
ma chérie mon coeur non c'est trop
larmoyant c'est pas mal non chère madame
trop froid ferait un truc entre les deux
espèces de kaunas
tu as décidé de me quitter j'aurais aimé
l'apprendre autrement que par un statut
facebook like et 450 x et qui disait je
ne suis plus en couple mais l'autre
qu'on n'est pas encore au courant lol
et ma mère qui fait le premier
commentaire je suis contente pour toi
n'oublie pas vital et faire des tests au
labo
malgré tout je je ne cesse de penser à
toi là martin disait un seul être vous
manque et tout est dépeuplé [ __ ] comme
il avait raison quoi puis que tu es
parti je me rends compte que tu étais la
seule personne que je connaissais
alors tu me reproche d'être possessif
jaloux ça va quand même pas de ma faute
si j'étais toujours trouvée sublime dans
cette robe noire que j'étais ramenait de
kaboul quoi je veux dire
tu te souviens quand je te disais foot à
kaboul
qu est-ce qu on rayait enfin je dis ça
je pouvais pas voir son visage
[Applaudissements]
tu trouvais que j'étais radin quelle
ingratitude
c'est qui qui a ouvert une tortue à
l'ouvre-boîte dans le jardin des plantes
pour faire les lunettes en écaille à
quinze mille balles
elle s'appelait audrey aussi je vous
avez un truc avec chez favre aller
revient à quoi tu as bien que je pars à
la dirige me ridiculise pour des jeux
pas quand même pas briser en six mois
une histoire de deux semaines
alors ok ok comme dans tous les couples
on a connu des bons et des mauvais
moments
souviens de la fois où la capote à
craquer trois mois plus tard à l'hôpital
je filmais ta fausse couche
mais c'est vrai qu'on a aussi connu des
moments pénibles
comme la fois où j'ai débarqué à
l'improviste que tu prenais un bac pour
te faire rire j'ai jeté un sèche-cheveux
branché dans la mousse qui
ne pas savoir - axema et c'est ta mère
qui était dans le bakoye
façon elle avait une maladie incurable
la ménopause
[Rires]
je n'oublierai jamais ton regard après
la soirée passée en boîte chez origin en
train de faire l'amour sur le capot de
la voiture
j'aurais tellement aimé que ce soit moi
[Applaudissements]
enfin c'est pas avec ce que je te
raconte j'espère que tu auras la
lucidité de reconnaître la grave erreur
que tu es en train de commettre parce
que des mecs comme moi tu en trouveras
pas souvent quoi et une fois on faisait
l'amour elle m'a dit le sexe est mieux
avec les sentiments j'ai dit bon écoute
c'est pas grave tu penses à ton ex si tu
préfères
je suis une perle et j'espère que ça te
ronge ps combien de fois j'aurais plus
de tromper mais je n'avais pas essayé de
friction non
elle va revenir moi je dis mach mans
bien traités quoi je découvre la
passivité façon quand on pense que 90 %
des femmes sont clitoridiennes à quoi
bon s'acharner à bander
alors est pas beau l'été et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux